ظلام دامس وبرد قارس هذا هو حال نحو مليون
ونصف مليون نسمه في اوكرانيا وتحديدا في
اكبر المدن الساحليه نعني هنا اوديسا
الرازحه في ظلمات كتبتها عليها طائرات
مسيره ايرانيه الصنع اطلقتها قوات روسيه
على ارض اوكرانيه تقع على ساحل البحر
الاسود فكان حالها حال الغريق في ليال
الشتاء لا يرحم فيها ولا القصف المجتهد
يهدئ مره واحده انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وصفه سكان اوديسا بالاسوا منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه وليس انتهاء بالهجمات الاخيره
التي حرمتهم لايام من الكهرباء بعد
استهدافه بنا الطاقه التحتيه في اوكرانيا
فال رئيس الاوكراني او الروسي كان قد
قالها بصريح العباره حينما سئل عن ضرب
منشات الطاقه واعترف بلى نحن نقصفها لكن
من بداها
الملائكه الذين ضربوا جسر القرن مش هذه
اكد الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسيلزكي ان
اجهزه الطوارئ تعمل على تخفيف انقطاع
الكهرباء في مناطق كثيره من اوكرانيا بعد
الهجمات الروسيه لاسيه مامنه اوديسا على
البحر الاسود